we're following major developments on
the Korean Peninsula this morning after
an historic meeting South Korea says
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un said
the north would be willing to give up
its nuclear weapons if certain
conditions are guaranteed he also agreed
to halt nuclear and missile tests if the
u.s. holds talks with his regime with
his regime North and South Korea also
agreed to hold the summit next month
been tracey's in beijing with what this
apparent breakthrough all means Ben good
morning good morning these are really
extraordinary developments with North
Korea the regime is now apparently
saying that it won't use nuclear or
conventional weapons on South Korea it's
also saying that it doesn't even need
its nuclear weapons at all if it is
given a security guarantee although it's
not entirely clear what that means now
all of this comes after this
extraordinary meeting between Kim
jong-un and a delegation from South
Korea that took place in Pyongyang on
Monday their dinner together included
Kim jong-un's wife and is said to have
lasted for more than four hours now
North Korean state media says that Kim
says that he hopes to write a new
history of national reunification all of
this could complicate the Trump
administration strategy of isolating
North Korea with sanctions the US has
said that it is open to diplomacy but
only if North Korea abandoned its
nuclear weapons program first now part
of that delegation to North Korea was
South Korea's head of National
Intelligence he is now likely to be able
to give US officials a good read on Kim
jong-un state of mind and whether these
rather extraordinary promises are to be
believed
Jon Ben Tracy and Beijing these are
extraordinary developments and this is
essentially what the administration has
been asking for to get to the table
thanks so much Ben